[Musique]
comme c'est bon les vacances
et comme il faut les aimer pour vouloir
partir
[Musique]
car les guichets sont avares dans les
gares transformées en salles d'attentes
courage et patience c'est la devise de
l'aspirant au départ
d'ailleurs pourquoi ne pas rester à
paris paris à ses plages artificielles
où l'on se marche sur les mains tout
aussi bien qu'ailleurs
[Musique]
et puis la scène vaut bien amer laberge
d'auteuil peut dès maintenant se nommer
la plage d'auteuil
bien que les guides ne passe pas encore
mention de cette villégiature familiale
les sages reste à paris dans ce pari
d'été ou au lac daumesnil
il retrouve la sologne au bois de
vincennes la forêt d'othe et ou
montmartre pour bien le mont blanc les
boîtes des quais recèle toujours les
plus belles aventures et seul le pêcheur
à la ligne et les amoureux savent quel
est le plus beau voyage
[Musique]